hey with someone named Samuel leaves and
in this video I'm gonna be talking about
deal sourcing and deal selling that's
packaging deals and selling them
specifically during lockdown is it
possible to package and sell deals
during lockdown and the answer is yes
now is it easy maybe not
I just packaged and sold a deal in the
last week 3600 pounds tastes something
that's the hardest three thousand six
fifty pounds I've earned in a very long
time it is not easy but it is possible
and if you can be doing one deal a month
right now and just kind of like just
about doing it and scraping through and
doing one deal emotes in lockdown just
think when lockdown finishes somebody's
gonna seem really really easy so like
when my personal trainer makes me
depressed UPS and he puts things on my
back and stuff and then when he takes
them off and I do a presser because all
this is easy it's the exact same if you
can package your deal join lockdown and
you can sell it to an investor drawing
lockdown and you can do that once a
month and make a few thousand pounds a
month you doing a lot better than most
deal sources right now who are quitting
who are just a home and thinking you
know what let's just have a little bit
of a relaxation holiday so it is
possible it is also hard let me answer a
few questions that have been coming in
from the DMS and then I want you to
comment your questions below as I am
going to probably do a follow-up video
to this video as I know that it's a big
subject and people have a lot of
questions so while I'm speaking if you
have a question that pops into your
brain comment below and I will do my
best to answer in the comments or do a
follow-up video on this so listen here's
the big problem the big problem is that
you can't view houses right now and you
can try but it's very difficult if you
pick up the phone right now and ring an
estate agent on Rightmove they're not
going to show you around the house so
that's the problem because how can you
find houses how can you find deals if
you can't view houses and worse than
that how can you sell a deal to an
investor when the investor can't even
view the house any investor knows that
you've not viewed the house like surely
this is just impossible well no it's not
impossible and here's why not because
just because you can't view the house
does not mean that the house
cannot be viewed now who's better at
looking around a house and weighing up
whether the inside of a house is in good
repair or bad repair you or a property
Building Surveyor well probably a
property Building Surveyor so if you
don't view the house but you send a
surveyor to go around the house and do a
building survey you can do all the due
diligence on the area and the demand and
the street and the agent and the power
team you can do all that online from
your laptop the only thing that you
can't do is you can't learn the house
but he put surveyor goes around the
house that's like belt and braces double
good double assurance to the to the
seller so when I spoke to the the seller
when I just sold a deal and I'd actually
had builders and stuff go around she I
said do this better than me come round
which gave her real confidence so that's
the first thing
secondly is you can do you can have
video tours pictures so so just because
you don't go out doesn't mean you can't
have a good account on the inside so
tender surveyor get builders get
pictures there are surveyors right now
that are still working so as long as
someone goes around and you are honest
with the investor and you say look oh I
haven't seen it I haven't been rounded
but I have negotiated the price I have
done the due diligence I have done this
that the other done these checks and
this is the price these are the checks
this is the video tour or the survey or
the builders quotes in the house and
here is what I have passed them the
details give them the address give them
everything
make them sign an NDA which is a
nondisclosure agreement which means that
when you pass them the property they
can't then look at the details and then
just cut you out because they've signed
a confidentiality agreement let them
look at the details and then if they're
happy take a fee off of them and listen
the investor doesn't even want to go and
see the house anyway normally I mean
sometimes they do and if they do you can
say to them well right now probably
gonna be difficult for you but pay me my
fee let's get the ball rolling and then
go and look at the house after lockdown
because it takes 2 or 3 months anyway
for a house to complete and if there's
anything that you're not happy with
down the line dance then of course
you're not a barge to buy the house
you're not buying it on auction terms or
according to Scottish law so you can
pull out and walk away so that's kind of
the gist on how you can deal package
deals and sell deals in lockdown as I
say it's not easy but if you can just do
one a month even if you just look for
properties that have already got surveys
on them just a look at the house been
surveyed or has you got any if you've
got builders quotes or anything if not
move to the next one that's gonna mean
you're going to lose a lot of deals but
you're still going to come across some
deals that you can package and sell
there are investors right now but
looking to buy houses they are looking
for cheap houses but they are looking
for houses right now they're buying so
here's my advice to you guys my advice
is to be positive my advice is to keep
working I saw someone post something
really stupid on them on I think it was
on think it was Facebook where they said
they were basically attacking people
that are saying to make the most of this
time so people are saying you know work
hard educate yourself learn come out of
this stronger and they were like the
heart now attacking that and say no just
relax and be safe and be at home listen
you can be at home and you can be safe
but you can also better your skills
better yourself and be an entrepreneur
and if you're not making money or
attempting to make money right now
during this time of lockdown then you
are not a true entrepreneur so my job as
your YouTube trainer and mentor is to
give you the skills to give you the
encouragement and to give you the
support in order to actually start
making some money to get through this
crazy time so if you have any questions
about deal sourcing or packaging or
anything like that comment below on this
video and I'll do my best to answer in
the comments or I'll do another video a
follow-up part thank you for your
support as well I hope you enjoyed the
documentary that apart yesterday where I
got a lease option agreement I packaged
and sold a deal I'm gonna be doing more
crazy videos I would have putting out
some really really awesome content
because believe me I'm studying right
now I'm speaking to some of my top
mentors I'm talking about what's going
on in the times what's happened with the
economy what are the best strategies one
of the strategies that are not so good
and everything that I'm learning I'm
gonna be sharing and putting it out on
YouTube so that you can learn as well so
if that sounds good smash the like
button also if you're not subscribed
when you watch my videos turn the
SUBSCRIBE notification and bow on so hit
subscribe turn the bed on and I love
see you in the next video thanks so much
I'll see you next time peace out